cela fait 12 ans que tu as refermé la
faille du mot
la paix n'a jamais été si fragile
comment va ton œil il ne sait toujours
pas réouvert
c'est vos
en réalité je m'appelle Yang
je cherche quelqu'un moi je suis
chasseur de prime je retrouve pas les
gens je les attrape
il a volé quelque chose qui appartenait
à ma sœur cette personne que vous
cherchez elle doit bien avoir un an
le meurtrier et le fugitif tu dois être
jeune chien j'en ai rien à faire de
quitter j'ai peur de personne
et en jean qui se trouve être la
personne qui est emprisonné ta mère sous
le pic du lotus ça suffit
de cadeau il est aveugle alors c'était
vrai
pour vaincre je suis prêt à tout
vers le ciel je m'élève
[Musique]